what's up guys bang bang federal reserve
just made the announcement they're gonna
hike interest rates by 25 basis points
point two five percent that means
they're gonna make the cost of capital
much more expensive now of course
inflation is at a 40-year high it's at
7.9 percent according to the official
numbers we even seen other countries
like canada 5.7
and ultimately what people thought the
fed was going to do was come in with a
bazooka they were going to have to
tackle this inflation battle but
everyone knows that they go ahead and
they actually increase the interest rate
too fast they're going to push us into a
recession and so ultimately rather than
doing a 0.5 percent increase a 50 basis
point increase they went ahead with just
.25 or 25 basis points this is like
bringing a water gun to the inflation
war it is unlikely to have any material
impact on the inflation that we're
currently seeing as we know the last
inflation numbers came from february
that was before commodity prices
exploded everything from oil to wheat to
nickel etc and the idea that gasoline is
going to be higher the idea that food is
going to be higher in march than it was
in february is pretty easy to see and so
ultimately the interest rate hike is the
step down a path to address inflation
but i fear that it is not going to be
anywhere near what we're going to need
so the federal reserve taking that step
but .25 come on now that's nothing
compared to what they're gonna need over
the long term hey you did you like this
video great we make five of them a day
and post them here on this channel make
sure you subscribe like the video and
see you next time